Hans it's been a while since we last
spoke yesterday a difficult game for you
but they well you are facing Lanier
Dominguez very good heritation and you
defend it well how do you feel right now
that was a pretty good game uh I wasn't
sure
between F6 and F5 like if you go to I
think that's the first moment right okay
I guess in the opening he repeated this
line which I didn't expect like if you
go after how did you choose to play the
Berlin I wasn't just choosing the Berlin
it was more interesting what to do
against the specific line because after
uh H3 like he played this against Rey
yes and he played Bishop B7 Rook D1
no D7 d77
1 and then here Bishop B7 and then it
went like G4 Knight H4
take take Knight D2 out of three okay
they had this so I wasn't expecting him
to repeat this so he went Knight C3
and I think he has a game against uh
Atari here maybe King eight
uh against Navara one of them but I'm
sure maybe he transposes somewhere
um oh yeah King state is correct
actually so King E8 is what I played yes
which is a mistake interesting it's a
move as well has been played by Jeffrey
Vallejo yeah maybe I mixed up the move
order um so G4
yeah okay this is oh no yeah I don't
think I mixed it yeah maybe it's just a
king to G2 this seems to have been
let's say at the moment where you made a
mistake with this move H5 were you
concerned about it so this was like I
think I just mixed it because here uh I
thought like I realized later on because
here F6 let's say there's a line okay I
think I just it's we're not transposed
like take take 94 and you're supposed to
take but this is just not the position
because it's nine of six but usually
there's you know Bishop G5 you know uh
Bishop G5
you know King and then King E7 Rook D3
and there was like this kind of game
yeah Bishop of five rookie three yeah uh
it was like grishek so maybe I don't
know but I remember this but uh clearly
something is lost along the way so uh I
uh I just these Berlin positions are so
hard to remember because they all look
so similar and you just don't know like
sometimes you can feel like you see
everything and then you just don't see
it yeah so okay did you chat with him
after the game
yeah but okay I guess take take a five
F6 yes and there's still some ways to
survive here I think yeah Rick the eight
I considered as well you know it's
probably the best I don't think it's oh
no yes yes okay yes now yes Rook d8
Bishop E3 and then F6 okay okay yes yes
and uh now you take take and then you go
1984 yeah Bishop G5 Bishop takes uh Pawn
takes Knight G5 King E7 yeah okay this
is this is the position no no oh yes you
with a work on d8 you cannot play um no
you play uh fg5 I guess right because
then you uh so go back yeah thank you
for the night yeah so that's why you
play FG not Bishop takes right got it
play a better version you can do this
and I'll be sure is what we were
discussing interesting yeah no but uh
can you check the database like maybe
I'm just mixing it like no it's it's not
in this position
so there is some like Bishop G5 King E7
stuff but I have no idea where that like
there there was a like a a game in this
I don't know maybe I think I remember
which one yeah you know the game I'm
talking about yeah so so I was I
remember that game but I wasn't exactly
sure how to get there uh so sometimes
actually having this incomplete
knowledge isn't great because you try to
get there and then if you don't get
there things can go very badly um but
anyways so he I played um he played F3
yeah okay take take F6 yeah okay so if
ef6 like GF Bishop before F5 like what I
don't understand yes now Rook H1 saying
F7 Rook 81 so maybe this is just
wow okay okay G5 okay so there are some
yeah there are some I think I have to
work on the Berlin game I think
everybody does it's just it's such a
weird thing you know because uh like
when you track it when you analyze it
you're like okay this is nice this is
nice and then you go to the game and
there's like four different move orders
and it's very very confusing were you
concerned that anybody
this is this is already fun okay so the
critical moment is probably yeses so he
plays I play F5 and he has to play Rook
H1 wow okay and then he has to play
Chief king of seven G5 yeah I consider
this but
this is also very weird
um I suspect that it's also not that bad
defense something like this okay if you
want maybe a wreckage five I still don't
think it's probably a rackage but I I
didn't see how it was like that bad yeah
and uh again to evaluate this is plus
one uh it's like I don't think it's hard
to see that over the board okay anyways
but yeah once he played G5 F5
uh yeah this position I thought was
already fine yeah okay yeah okay now
yeah he he lets us happen okay I thought
yeah there are a few options okay Bishop
E3 was interesting I also considered
Bishop D2 but this idea of bringing the
bishop away I I considered yeah and I
thought C5 F4 right C5 yeah
and uh okay I thought I could go Bishop
G6 and with the bishop on C6 it was sort
of hard to make progress but I always
have this idea I thought like
even sacking this exchange of course I
got the best version
um but I was never too concerned and he
was spending so much time like he was
literally just tanking yeah so here okay
it's just
it's just there's nothing at this point
you felt like yeah okay I I even was a
bit maybe cautious to play A5 A4 I just
was you know like just uh okay I don't
think there was anything I just have a
fortress
okay there's nothing nothing to do here
but okay I think there's a I think
everyone every chess player has a lot of
work to do in the Berlin game yeah I
think I've spent so much time looking at
it but nothing seems to to stick because
uh just there's just too many options
how do you get yourself back on track uh
after a difficult loss like yesterday's
loss well uh I think Fabiano played very
well so it was I was not nothing to be
too too uh ashamed of um and of course
it's a very long event
and um you know it's 13-game Marathon
okay one loss against uh Fabiano is not
like the worst thing in the world uh so
uh
again you know when this chest of play
and uh also the fact that there's a rest
there now is giving me some relief you
know it's like you're crawling
desperately towards the rest day
um but no he played incredibly well
despite the fact that he gave me some
chances that was very very impressed
what's the plan for the rest day
any fun stuff fan activities no no just
uh just preparing and you know studying
chess and maybe some Berlin game and you
can do some some work here because I
think this is something you can study
for your entire life and still not
understand but uh I'll try my best to
get there guys any questions no just uh
yeah good luck on the rest day yeah yeah
yeah with the uh prep uh Hans uh nice uh
today yeah and I was just wondering
maybe Hans can share with us how what is
his routine looks like every day like
let's say when you are preparing for
your games what what else you are doing
I'm not a few stalkers I don't want this
you know I don't want to get the uh the
paparazzi and TMZ information on where
are my beans from times of the day so I
will keep that to myself right right
okay but uh I have a very
I I have a routine that I try to stick
to and uh
do you put glasses on when you go
outside you put like some hats
not really but the hair is is a hat
usually helps because the hair is
usually the giveaway right
um but you know let's just say that it's
hard for me to order food
do you feel that you're popular now I uh
ubereats isn't that great here
unfortunately
um but it's better than Miami yeah it's
no much no Miami has a much better
um
um you know Miami had a more selective
but you know the Central West End is
just such a I could walk you know
everywhere in Miami I didn't leave my
hotel once so uh here it's walkable so I
prefer to go outside sometimes and just
you know it's a very nice neighborhood I
really like it but I will not say which
restaurants I go to every day
because to be honest uh I already
um
yes that's that's that's that's all I
should say do you have a discount in
this place so why do you hide it let's
just say that um you know I I was making
an order and they knew my order and the
guy said to me you know this order
speaks for itself
and uh so I'm not really enjoying the
fact that I cannot make a takeout order
in privacy but it's it's it's
um you know there are worse things that
you have to deal with on a daily basis
but again I'm here to play chess and
enjoy the great Cuisine of the Central
West End yes you have to make a fake
Uber account
yeah that that as well thankfully no no
one you know if I did Uber routes and
they came directly to my room that
wouldn't be great
um but uh thankfully where I'm staying
you need a room key to get to the floor
that is some added security yeah as well
yeah thank you thank you Hans I want to
turn our attention to some games that
are really heating up and